so Your Big Break obviously was on X
Factor and I came up on idol so
um you came up with a group which I
think is cool I think
I need to know if that
one of them I was very lonely like off
the top like I was 19 a little older
whenever I started but like I I was very
lonely and I think that must have been
cool like that you had like buddies to
lean on and like do y'all still have
that do you have that like you we have a
group well we have a group text we can't
tell anyone about but we have a group
text like with The Voice coaches but
like but do y'all still do you have that
do you have that kind of camaraderie I
just I would love that yeah no we were
so especially on the show we were so
lucky like because you would see all the
other artists melting all the time over
everything yeah we were just 16 17 18 19
whatever we were yeah
something that you have people to lean
on I just I would have loved that it was
so fun yeah really I'd do it again yeah
that's why I'm doing the voice
I love doing the voice for that reason
it is actually cool full circle moment
that you get to say I've been in here I
don't like that that's your pitch though
because that's my pitch yeah she used to
like I came from a show like this and uh
and then I was like wait to see what
I've got I was like damn it me too
um but yeah no yeah of course we speak
constantly so it's uh that's cool little
thing to have yeah I was like I always
looked at groups like that I'm like oh
that would have been cool yeah so just
have someone to you one on your own it's
okay no this is the greatest thing so
funny wait so we're doing a skit for the
voice
I thought One Direction won
because you did in life like like you
Hugo actually came in third and I was
like what I was like I was like because
I didn't watch I just like knew that's
where you came from but like
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm going home